marke bei den zweit impfungen den
wichtigen zweite impfung stand heute
morgen sind 10,9 millionen fast elf
millionen deutsche voll geschützt durch
eine doppelte impfung
wir haben 32,6 millionen das sind 39,2
prozent die bereits eine erste impfung
erhalten haben gestern es erneut über
ein prozent der deutschen geimpft worden
diese zahlen sind ja irgendwie
mittlerweile so ist wenn es eine million
impfungen tag sind 900.000 dann das
irgendwie schon fast selbstverständlich
geworden ist aber wenn wir uns erinnern
vor drei vier wochen waren die zahlen
noch deutlich andere und deswegen ist es
wichtig dass auch wahrzunehmen denn an
weihnachten war 0 prozent der deutschen
geimpft an ostern waren etwa zwölf
prozent der deutschen mindestens einmal
geimpft jetzt zu pfingsten werden es 40
prozent sein die mindestens einmal in
form sind und zum start in das
sommerquartal zum start im juli werden
aus heutiger sicht über 50 prozent
mindestens einmal geimpft worden sein
und auch mal zur einordnung wenn wir
eine impfbereitschaft von 70 prozent
annehmen und berücksichtigen dass sich
aktuell nur die über 16-jährigen impfen
lassen können weil wir nur dort einen
zugelassenen impfstoff haben denn haben
jetzt etwa zwei drittel aller
impfwilligen und barren in deutschland
zwei drittel aller erwachsenen eine
erste impfung bekommen also alle
erwachsenen die vermutlich bereit sind
sich impfen zu lassen und das macht
denkt ich sehr klar deutlich auf welchen
weg wir sind wir sind auf einem guten
weg und ich finde das dürfen wir auch
mal so wahrnehmen klar heißt es
gleichzeitig realistisch zu bleiben
wunder sind nicht zu erwarten wunder
können wir auch keine versprechen wir
können immer nur so viel verkaufen wie
wir auch an impfstoff geliefert bekommen
und nur verhelfen was da ist aber ich
finde die entwicklung der letzten wochen
zeigt auch deutlich wie stark an dynamik
haben gewinnen können und dass wir nach
jetzigem stand noch deutlich vor ende
des sommers noch vor ende september
geben in deutschland der will ein
impfangebot werden gemacht haben können
das jedenfalls hätte vor zwei monaten
kaum jemand erwartet und ich finde das
ist erst mal als bestandsaufnahme jetzt
ende meint auch eine gute erkenntnis und
deswegen bei allem ärger beim warten auf
den termin
es geht jetzt um wochen nicht um monate
wir haben vor allem ältere und kranke
menschen zuerst geimpft diejenigen die
ein hohes risiko hatten und haben schwer
zu erkranken
mittlerweile sind über 70 prozent im
bundesschnitt der über 60-jährigen aller
über 60-jährigen mindestens einmal
geimpft und diese priorisierung war
wichtig um menschenleben zu schützen das
war und ist keine bürokratie das schützt
menschen leben und gleichzeitig macht es
der fortschritt in der impfkampagne nun
möglich wenn wir über 40 prozent der
deutschen mindestens einmal geimpft
haben dann zum siebten juni die
priorisierung aufzuheben
und bei diesem nächsten schritten müssen
wir beides sein pragmatisch und geduldig
pragmatisch heißt dass wir immer
flexibler werden können beim impfen in
den betrieben die ab dem 17 juni
regelhaft mit eingebunden werden in die
ems kampagne in allen praxen die sich
beteiligen in allen stadtteilen und
sozialen schichten und frau
oberbürgermeisterin rica wird uns ja
gleich aus der arbeit vor ort in weiß
gar nicht wie viel größte stadt eine der
größten städte deutschlands vierter
bitte die viertgrößte stadt deutschlands
berichten können wir auch mit sehr
unterschiedlichen situationen in
unterschiedlichen stadtteilen angebote
so gemacht werden können und gemacht
werden sollen dass wir tatsächlich auch
diejenigen erreichen die vielleicht
nicht von sich aus einen termin beim
arzt oder ein impfzentrum machen würde
oder wo es auch in manchen stadtteilen
einfach zu wenig ärztinnen und ärzte
gibt auch das ist ja eine situation die
wir haben
wir wollen das impfen so einfach machen
wie es geht
gelegenheit macht impfung das ist das
motto für die nächsten wochen also
pragmatisch sein aber auch geduldig sein
nicht jeder kann sofort brand kommen
daher kann ich auch nur bitte nicht
jetzt schon alle die ärztin und ärzte
und die impfzentren bedrängen
verständnis und geduld haben
mit dem praxisteams wenn es nicht gleich
einen termin gibt und wenn sie unbedingt
sauer sein wollen weil es vielleicht
nicht gleich beim ersten anruf klappt
dann seien sie im zweifel sauer auf mich
aber bitte haben sie verständnis für
diejenigen die in den arztpraxen die
arzthelferin und arzthelfer die erste
und erste alle die dort jeden tag mit
helfen wirklich ihr bestes geben um
jedem schnellstmöglich ein herz
arzttermin impftermin möglich zu machen
also pragmatismus und geduld sind
gefragt wir haben es bis hierhin
zusammen geschafft das schaffen wir nun
beim impfen auch und genau diese
kombination aus zuversicht und vorsicht
aus impfen und aufeinander achtgeben war
wichtig um die dritte welle zu brechen
das haben wir gemeinsam geschafft die
dritte welle ist gebrochen aber die
kombination aus impfungen vorsicht
bleibt auch wichtig um diesen trend zu
verstetigen
jede woche die wir die zahlen die
infektionszahlen weiter runter bringen
erhöht die chancen auf einen wirklich
guten sommer deshalb bleibt mein
dringender appell jetzt auch über das
pfingstwochenende die pandemie ist noch
nicht vorbei genießen sie die feiertage
genießen wir gemeinsam die feiertage
aber bleiben wir dabei vorsichtig gerade
jetzt wo es nicht mehr lange dauert bis
das impfen tatsächlich auch einen
spürbaren unterschied für den
pandemiefall auf insgesamt wird machen
können und deswegen im zweifel vor allem
draußen treffen wer noch nicht voll
geschützt ist durch die impfung in
zweifel und unbedingt sich regelmäßig
testen lassen auch vor treffen mit
anderen abstand und maske im alltag auch
weiterhin infektionszahlen runter
impfzahlen hoch wenn wir diese
kombination miteinander in den nächsten
wochen schaffen dann haben wir aussicht
auf einen guten sommer dankeschön
ersparen herr professor willi guten
morgen meine damen und herren die
weltgesundheitsorganisation hat stand
gestern insgesamt 1
dort 64 millionen kubik fälle gemeldet
und darunter sind mehr als 3,4 millionen
todesfälle
was heißt das für uns diese pandemie hat
unsere welt immer noch im griff das
dürfen wir nicht vergessen in
deutschland aber da geht die sieben
tages inzidenz weiter kontinuierlich
zurück momentan liegt sie bei 67,3 pro
100.000 einwohnern
auch geht sie zurück in allen
bundesländern der großteil der
landkreise liegt inzwischen auch bei
unter 100 und das sieht man denke ich
auch ganz gut an der deutschlandkarte
die in unserem dashboard jeden tag zu
sehen ist die war lange zeit dunkelrot
und doch hält sie sich immer weiter auf
auch die instanzen in allen
altersgruppen gehen übrigens zurück
glücklicherweise auch aktuell deutlich
bei den jüngeren
es werden im moment auch beispielsweise
weniger ausbrüche in schulen und den
kitas gemeldet und die ausbrüche die
noch gemeldet werden sind insgesamt auch
kleiner
der rückgang der fallzahlen macht sich
endlich auch in den kliniken bemerkbar
auf den intensivstationen liegen zwar
aktuell immer noch rund 3500 patienten
aber die zahl ist in den letzten tagen
ebenfalls gesunken
und wir hoffen dass bald auch die
todesfälle in verbindung mit 9 10
zurückgehen
hier sehen wir seit langer zeit seit
einiger zeit ein plateau von etwa 1300
toten pro woche was natürlich immer noch
eine schrecklich hohe zahl ist
insgesamt sind ja in deutschland nach
den meldungen und 87.000 menschen im
zusammenhang mit 19 verstorben also um
das noch einmal ganz klar auf den punkt
zu bringen wir haben in den letzten
wochen gemeinsam sehr sehr viel erreicht
und zwar durch unser aller bereitschaft
sich weiterhin die maßnahmen zu halten
und natürlich auch durch unsere
bereitschaft uns impfen zu lassen
die impfbereitschaft ist sehr hoch das
zeigen auch aktuelle befragungen des
robert koch-instituts demnach sind rund
73 prozent der befragten geben an dass
sie sich auf jeden fall impfen lassen
wollen und und zusätzliche zehn prozent
sagen dass sie sich auf jeden fall
impfen lassen
als nicht und dafür möchte ich mich bei
allen sehr herzlich bedanken
das ist sinnvoll das ist wirksam und das
ist auch verantwortungsvoll
wir schützen nämlich und selbst und wir
schützen natürlich damit auch andere
aber vergessen wir nicht wie die sagt
befinden uns immer noch mitten in der
pandemie und insgesamt sind die fallzahl
natürlich immer noch zu hoch die
krankheit lasse es weiterhin ungleich
verteilt die inzidenz und die
sterblichkeit in seit mitte der zweiten
welle in regionen die besonders
benachteiligt sind am höchsten
mögliche gründe hierfür sind armut armut
ist mit mehr vor erkrankungen assoziiert
aber auch die lebensverhältnisse wohnen
dicht und bedingungen spielen sicher
eine rolle und natürlich auch die
arbeitsbedingungen wie prekäre
beschäftigung und ich bin deshalb froh
dass frau oberbürgermeisterin reka uns
gleich ein paar lösungsvorschläge
offeriert die auf der hand liegen die
aber eben auch umgesetzt werden müssen
bislang sind 12,5 prozent der menschen
in deutschland geimpft es müssen aber
mehr als 80 prozent ein schutz aufbauen
entweder durch eine vollständige impfung
oder durch eine durchgemachte infektion
und eine impfung plus impfung dann
kriegen wir dieses videos unter
kontrolle
dieses virus ist unser gemeinsamer
gegner lassen sie uns den sommer nutzen
um die virus ausbreitung so weit wie
möglich zu unterdrücken damit wir gut
durch herbst und winter kommen deshalb
bleiben im moment neben den impfungen
die anderen maßnahmen auch so wichtig
dass abstand halten die hygieneregeln
das tragen von masken und in innenräumen
besonders das lüften die reduktion von
kontakten
das nutzen der korona warb die annahme
von test angeboten mit den
entsprechenden konsequenzen des
testergebnisses und natürlich bei
erkältungssymptomen bitte zu hause
bleiben damit man niemand anderes
ansteckt bitte halten sie diese
maßnahmen weiter durch
bieten wir diesem virus weiterhin die
stirn das haben wir jetzt monatelang
gemacht das schaffen wir auch noch die
letzten wochen und vor allem im hinblick
auf die kommenden feiertage und ganz
besonders dort wo jetzt auch erste
öffnung schritte möglich sind wir dürfen
nicht zulassen dass das virus wieder
oberhand gewinnt weil wir auf einmal zu
viel wollen
vor zwei wochen hatte ich gesagt diese
pandemie ist wie ein prall gefüllter
luftballon den wir gemeinsam unter der
wasseroberfläche halten müssen
mittlerweile hat dieser ballon
tatsächlich nicht mehr ganz so viel luft
aber wenn wir ihnen jetzt loslassen
springt er immer noch unkontrolliert
über die wasseroberfläche
sie schaffen es nämlich nach wie vor nur
gemeinsam diesen ballon
herunterzudrücken und wir brauchen dafür
wirklich jeden einzelnen jede einzelne
geimpft oder ungeimpft wenn wir jetzt
maßnahmen ignorieren und zu früh öffnen
dann springt dieser ballon wieder an die
oberfläche
das sollte uns allen bewusst sein ohne
die massnahmen würde sich das virus im
moment sehr rasch wieder ausbrechen die
pandemie ist noch nicht vorbei die
gefahr ist noch nicht gebannt
lassen sie uns den sommer so gut wie
möglich nutzen und weiter gut
aufeinander achtgeben mit zu wenigen
erkrankten wie möglich wenn wir weiter
zusammenhalten dann bringen wir
gemeinsam dieses virus nieder
herzlichen dank professor wiler verräter
bitte morgen sehr geehrter herr zentiva
nie sehr verehrt der minister sehr
geehrte professor wieder meine damen und
herren ich bedanke mich zunächst bei der
bundespressekonferenz und bei herrn
minister sparen für die einladung die
möglichkeit hier heute zu sprechen
anders als berlin und hamburg ist ja
köln eine million stadt die kein
bundesland ist und deswegen natürlich
nur sehr beschränkt in der lage auch
eigene regelungen zu treffen und wenn
ich auch eine große befürworterin
größtmöglicher einheitlichkeit der
regeln bin dann bin ich doch davon
überzeugt dass es regionale anpassungen
geben muss weil in den kommunen am
besten entschieden werden kann was genau
notwendig ist wir haben zum beispiel in
köln mit der einrichtung einer task
force will nach ab
gruppen seit märz 2020 also sofort nach
meinem besuch bei ihnen hier und da hat
regelmäßig die mitarbeitenden in den
pflegeeinrichtungen und die
bewohnerinnen bewohner getestet und
haben so einen große ausbreitung
innerhalb der einrichtung verhindern
können ebenso haben unsere mobilen
einsatzteams die zu den corona
infizierten nach hause fahren wenn wir
im rahmen der betreuung durch das
gesundheitsamt festgestellt haben dass
sich der zustand verschlechtert hat dazu
beigetragen dass die sterberate in köln
schlimm genug aber immerhin sehr viel
niedriger ist als deutschlandweit mit
einem modellprojekt zur regelmäßigen
testung von kinder jugendlichen und
mitarbeitenden in allen kitas und
schulen haben wir in kooperation mit der
uniklinik köln auch einen wesentlichen
beitrag geleistet ein sicheres umfeld zu
schaffen weil wir ja schulen und
kindergärten möglichst aufrecht erhalten
können
die pcr test methode hat das land nrw
nun landesweit eingeführt
eine andere der eigenen kölner maßnahmen
und deswegen bin ich heute hier war dass
wir uns sehr früh angeschaut haben die
sich das infektionsgeschehen in den
einzelnen stadtteilen wir haben 86 in
köln abgebildet hat nachdem wir erste
erkenntnisse gewonnen hatten haben wir
dann die untersuchung gemeinsam mit dem
fraunhofer-institut vertieft und
festgestellt und wissenschaftlich
bestätigt bekommen dass es unter
bestimmten voraussetzungen zu einem
erhöhten infektionsrisiko kommt und das
hat eben wie herr professor wähler eben
schon gesagt hat insbesondere mit der
wohnsituation vieler menschen auf engem
raum zu tun das ist ein haupttreiber für
die infektion und wir haben uns dann
dazu entschlossen als maßnahmen der
gefahrenabwehr denn dieser der ihn
verlass auch so vor in dem besonders
betroffenen stadtteilen also in den
wohlhabenden sozialräumen wie ich sie
nenne unabhängig von einer priorisierung
den menschen die zwar kein höchst
persönliches risiko haben
aber die die sozialdemokratischen
faktoren in sich vereinen ein
impfangebot zu machen
wir haben uns an das land nrw gewandt
mit der bitte uns dafür zusätzlichen
impfstoff zur verfügung zu stellen
möglichst der nur einmal zuvor impfen
ist und unsere ersten schätzungen gingen
davon aus dass wir rund 750 impfdosen am
tag verhelfen werden können
das land nrw hat uns erst mal 1000
impfdosen geliefert zwar ja auch ein
modellprojekt wo man erstmal gucken
musste wie das wirkt und wir haben dann
begonnen mit überhang dosen auch aus
unserem impfzentrum damit wir die aktion
wirklich starten konnten
wir haben anfang mai am dritten mai
begonnen ein niederschwelliges angebot
zu machen den bewohnern wohl in arabien
sozialräume und zwar gleich vor ihrer
haustür auf einem zentralen platz in
viertel aus sicht der gefahrenabwehr
erschien es uns notwendig maßnahme
schwerpunkte mit hohem infektionen in
fact in wohlen sozialraum mit hohen
infektionsraten zu setzen um die
infektionsgefahr mick und auch eine
mögliche ausbreitung des dynamic in
andere stadtteile in andere bahnen räume
abzumildern oder zu unterbrechen und
schon die impfaktion in den ersten
beiden sozialräumen haben gezeigt dass
wir mit diesem mobilen impfangebot
menschen erreicht haben für die eine
anmeldung im zentrum oder auch der
besuch beim hausarzt eine hohe hürde
darstellt für morgen das ist wirklich
eine gute nachricht hat uns das land
eine lieferung von weiteren zusätzlichen
impfdosen für die impfungen in den
hohlen arabien sozialräumen angekündigt
und wir werden daher am montag und
dienstag in dem stadtteil finkenberg
einem ebenfalls besonders betroffenen
stadtteil impfung vor ort anbieten
das gelingt weil wir durch eine
persönliche zum großen teil
muttersprachliche ansprache durch
streetworker bringen
streetworker durch sozialarbeiterinnen
und sozialarbeiter kultur mittleren und
auch stadtteilmütter die menschen
motivieren sich impfen zu lassen
um das angebot auf andere honorable
sozialräume auszudehnen benötigen wir
natürlich dringend ein weiteres zusatz
kontingent die bislang vom land
zugesagten 6500 impfdosen für
schwerpunkt impfungen können da nur ein
anfang sein
aber es ist nicht mehr als ein tropfen
auf den heißen stein
die schleppende impfung schützen nicht
nur die bewohnerinnen und bewohner das
war mir von anfang an ganz wichtig auch
zu kommunizieren die aufgrund ihrer
lebenssituation eben ein deutlich
höheres risiko haben sich zu infizieren
dann schwer zu erkranken sondern sie
schützen auch unsere gesundheitssysteme
uns alle und das sind die menschen die
unsere städte am leben halten ja das
sind die reinigungskräfte die
kassiererinnen und kassierer und ich
freue mich dass wir mit diesem projekt
so viel aufmerksamkeit bekommen haben
dass andere diesen erfolg auch in ihren
eigenen städten nachahmen danke
herzlichen dank dann kommen wir zu
fragen als vorbemerkung ich habe bereits
15 junge sowohl online als auch im saal
ich bitte deshalb um disziplin eine
frage eine nachfrage und möglicherweise
auch bei der beantwortung ein wenig
disziplin die erste hat dann herr rinke
erspart ich hätte ganz gerne zum
impfpass gefragt und digital nachdem
sich gestern auch eben wenn man sich
geeinigt hatte auf einer gemeinsamen
plattform hätte ich jetzt ganz gerne von
ihnen gewusst wie denn die digitalen
daten in deutschland und von wem problem
und wie sie erfasst werden sollen ist
die hausärzte sperren sich die bisher
verhängten nochmal nachträglich zu
erfassen also wer soll das tun und wie
soll das geschickt also zuerst einmal
ist es gut dass es gestern diese
einigung gegeben hat für die europäische
union auch auf einen einheitlichen
rechtsrahmen aber eben auch damit
verknüpft der einheitliche standards
und ich will darauf hinweisen dass dass
wir das sehr genau natürlich verfolgt
habe weil es zwischendurch immer mal
wieder diskussionen gab ob es ein
zusätzliches feld zusätzliche
informationen oder anderes braucht wenn
das so wäre hätten wir gleich und zwar
auch alle anderen 26 staaten natürlich
nochmal an den entwicklungen anpassen
müssen und es ist gott sei dank sage ich
ausdrücklich miteinander so gelungen
dass der kompromiss so ist dass wir mit
dem was wir aufgesetzt haben was
entwickelt ist auch genau auf dem
richtigen auf dem guten weg sind
wir haben anders als andere länder kein
zentrales register wir überhaupt keine
zentralen register haben
das ist übrigens eine lehre für mich aus
dieser pandemie und ich hoffe dass wir
das endlich schaffen was irgendwie wir
seit vielen jahren in den deutschen
debatten schaffen zentrale register
nicht immer nur als bedrohung
wahrzunehmen sondern auch als chance
wenn sie richtig gemacht sind wenn der
datenschutz stimmt dafür schnell
bürgerinnen und bürger erreichen zu
können in bestimmten situationen und
umständen dadurch dass wir kein
zentrales register haben dann keine
zentralen dateien als bund stadt hat ein
melderegister aber schon das land keines
mehr müssen wir tatsächlich da wo die
impfung schon voll stattgefunden hat
also beide impfungen stattgefunden haben
dann einer entsprechenden gewünschten
digitalen impfpass nachtragen lassen
diejenigen die noch geimpft werden die
die zweitimpfung noch haben nach
einführung des passes oder überhaupt
noch games werden die können natürlich
dann gleich mit abschluss der m-serie
auch den digitalen impfpass im
impfzentrum in der arztpraxis
ausgestellt bekommen aber es geht jetzt
um diejenigen die bereits die zweite
impfung gehabt haben werden dass wenn
einige millionen dann doch sein
und dann wollen wir das in den
impfzentren in den arztpraxen und in den
apotheken eine entsprechende nach
eintragung sozusagen oder übertragung in
den digitalen infos weiß möglich ist
warum geht das nicht überall weil wir
auch eine rückkopplung brauchen an die
telematikinfrastruktur es ist ja
verbunden über sichere leitung und die
haben die apotheken haben die arztpraxen
und die impfzentren werden die auch
haben dann mit einem entsprechenden
gateway
wo ihr auch dann die qr-codes erstellt
werden und die dinge hinterlegt werden
woran wir arbeiten mit den ländern und
den kommunen ist da wo es lokal
entsprechende daten gibt der geimpften
dass man dann dass möglicherweise auch
über eine entsprechende schriftliche
übersendung des qr codes wird machen
können wie groß die zahl derjenigen ist
die wir so sehr einfach würden erreichen
können
daran arbeiten wir gerade mit den
ländern habe ich kurz nachfragen aber
die hausärzte weigern sich doch im
moment also wie wollen sie die
überzeugung mit geld oder mit
anweisungen der anweisung machen gar
nichts sondern immer ein guter
kooperation also das ist ja so immer in
der öffentlichen debatte wer sind jetzt
immer die ärzte oder die politiker oder
die oberbürgermeister das ist halt eine
vielfalt immer und einfach eine vielfalt
der stimmen manchmal sagen ja sogar
dieselben leute im zeitablauf
unterschiedliches also dieselben leute
die mir vor vier sechs wochen noch
gesagt haben die curry sierung müsste in
den arztpraxen aber es dringend weg weil
sie aufwand bedeutet dieselben nicht die
gleichen dieselben sagen jetzt dass das
aber mit dem wegfall der priorisierung
dann doch etwas mehr aufwand macht ich
glaube dass wieder am ende jetzt
miteinander mit den ärztinnen und ärzten
die hat wirklich das ist ja ein
zusätzlicher aufwand sehr engagiert mit
ihren teams da sind eine gute lösung
haben das gleiche wird jetzt hier auch
passieren wir nehmen ja sehr bewusst die
apotheken mit rein und es gibt auch eine
bereitschaft bei vielen apothekerinnen
und apothekern wenn der aufwand vergütet
wird natürlich soll für ärztin und erste
wie für die apothekerin apotheker der
zusätzliche aufwand vergütet werden dann
da auch mitzuhelfen und wenn 60.000
70.000 arztpraxen und 20.000 apotheken
gemeinsam das stemmen dann ist das auch
machbar
in einer überschaubaren zeit ja mit
zusätzlichem aufwand den wir dann aber
auch verbinden wollen da fühle ich eine
frage von eva ellermann
ard-hauptstadtstudio hinzu
sie fragt wann wird der digitale
impfausweise wirklich nutzbar sein für
die bundes bewilligt es bleibt bei
meiner aussage zweite hälfte des zweiten
quartals die hat
tag begonnen und das heißt in den
nächsten wochen aber ich sehe sie mir
einfach nach wir mussten jetzt einfach
abwarten die entscheidung gestern in der
europäischen union auf europäischer
ebene damit auch klar ist dass sozusagen
sich keine entscheidenden parameter mehr
verändern
trotzdem wurde natürlich weiter
gearbeitet die diskussion mit
datenschutz und der datensicherheit lars
läuft alles gut es läuft alles intensiv
aber ich habe jetzt in meinen drei
jahren als bundesminister für gesundheit
so viele digitale projekte manches
gemeinsam mit dem lka erlebt das ist
immer besser ist sie positiv zu
überraschen wenn wir ein paar tage
früher fertig sind als mit einem datum
nachher dann nicht ganz hinzu kommen
aber zweiter hälfte des zweiten quartals
steht alaska herr minister es gibt ja ob
sie die maske aufsetzen ja und wenn sie
mich noch gut hören konnten das ist
selbstverständlich
okay der minister es gibt auch im
kontext impfpässe beunruhigende
nachrichten dass eben dieser sache mal
zettelwirtschaft blätter die man hat
oder so zu rücken ist wie man die von
hund zum beispiel hat doch eben nicht so
sicher sind auch wir sogar gefälscht
werden deswegen vielleicht noch mal die
frage warum es doch so lange dauert bis
ein sicherer digitaler impfpass zur
verfügung steht denn länder werben ja
bereits sehr stark jetzt im hinblick auf
den urlaub und touristen spanien
griechenland anderer und da würde sich
doch wahrscheinlich jeder eine sichere
nachweis möglichkeit wünschen für sich
und natürlich auch für andere
warum zieht sich das so was hinter die
gründe also zuerst einmal muss ich jetzt
mit zwei dingen sap an ja gesagt
aufrollen das würde ich nie so klar
stellen das eine ist das thema urlaub
auch mit dem papier ausweis ist das
reisen möglich
der gelbe vero ausweis ist ein velo aus
weisweiler internationaler standard ist
das finde ich immer mal wieder wichtig
weil ich gelegentlich selbst im eigenen
bekanntenkreis mitkriege nach dem motto
wenn ich nicht das digital hub kann ich
nicht reisen das ist nicht so dass
internationaler impfpass der ja selbst
wenn er gelbfieberimpfung weltweit
entsprechend auch gültigkeit hat also es
ist vielleicht nicht so
praktisch aber es ist deswegen kein
nicht grund für die mobilität wenn das
papier in papierform vorliegt das zweite
ist dass fälschungs thema ist ja eines
was gesicht genau so stellt dann
übertrag natürlich und es muss ja auch
nicht sozusagen jeder es muss übrigens
nicht jeder digital machen werde
weiterhin papieren ausschließlich will
kann das auch machen aber die
eigentliche und das ist ja auch da sind
wir beim thema vergütung die frage von
herrn rinker auch gerade
es ist ja auch eine prüf aufgabe damit
verbundenen dieses medizinische dokument
impfpass tatsächlich auf seine
richtigkeit zu überprüfen und ärztinnen
und ärzte und vor allem übrigens auch
apotheker prüfen jeden tag medizinische
dokumente auf ihre richtigkeit
rezepte betäubungsmittel rezepte viele
andere unterlagen und deswegen ist der
entscheidende punkt und sozusagen die
fehler oder fälschungs anfälligkeit
gegeben mit blick auf den digitalen
impfnachweis beim übertrag noch da
werden wir es nicht also das ist am ende
kann man das ja nur nach fachlicher
augenschein kontrolle machen nicht zu
100 prozent ausschließen können ich kann
immer nur wieder sagen
am ende wird rückt man sich selbst weil
man sich selbst ein schutz vor gaukelt
dem man nicht hat falls man einen
gefälschten ausweis hätte den impfschutz
macht man zuerst einmal für sich selbst
und sein umfeld und ich für den für die
bundesregierung
das finde ich erstens wichtig zweitens
ist es sehr wichtig wenn wir jetzt auch
gestern hat der bundestag das gesetz
beschlossen auch die verschärfung der
strafmassnahmen bei denjenigen die das
machen die solche dokumente ausstellen
und auch manche klarstellung gemacht mit
sehr harten strafen und auch sehr klaren
ansagen was dann eben entsprechend
passiert und das ist dass wir es jetzt
adressieren warum es so lange dauert
sind wie gesagt die technischen vorgaben
die europäischen abstimmung wenn wir es
jetzt schaffen als europäische union mit
27 mitgliedstaaten das mit einem einem
qr-code auf meinem handy ich in italien
im restaurant das ding vor zeit und der
qr-code leser in italien das erkennt als
impfnachweis oder in finnland oder in
porto
dann ist das weltweit einmalig dass es
einen digitalen etwas gibt der mehr als
eine insellösung einer nation ist den
usa gibt es nicht mal einen
einheitlichen bundes impfpass bisher und
insofern haben wir da die chance maßstab
zu setzen aber dieser maßstab muss im
datenschutz und datensicherheit voll
umfassen und das dauert manchmal länger
als andere dinge eine frage von sascha
meyer dpa
frage an den minister und professor
wieder in niedersachsen wird für möglich
die masten pflicht im einzelhandel in
frage gestellt halten sie das für
vertretbar und liegen ja die frage hätte
ja ich kann mich noch sehr gut erinnern
letztes jahr im frühjahr war das robert
koch institut anfang sehr zurückhaltend
mit der empfehlung von masten das lag
daran dass zu dieser zeit noch nicht
genügend erkenntnisse da waren
insbesondere wussten wie zu dieser zeit
ja nicht dass so viel von dem virus
schon von menschen ausgeschieden werden
die noch gar nicht krank sind und das
spielt für diese ganze pandemie eine
unglaublich große rolle
und als das klar wurde haben wir dann
auch und ich meine mich zu erinnern am
vierten april 2020 in einem
pressebriefing das tragen von masken von
alltags masten damals auch empfohlen
und natürlich sind medizinische
schutzmasken also mund nasenschutz
ironische massen und fsp zwei masten
noch wirksamer auch zwei masten
insbesondere für den selbstschutz sogar
insofern bin ich froh dass es immer mehr
evidenz gibt gerade gestern glaube ich
ist eine neue publikation von kollege
unter der federführung von einem max
planck institut in mainz erschienen die
zeigt wie wirksam das tragen von masken
eben nicht nur im krankenhaus sondern
auch in alltagssituationen ist insofern
werde ich meine maske noch lange tragen
und ich hoffe dass diese erkenntnis auch
weiter hält wenn wir jetzt lockern
dann muss dieser basis schutz wie wir
das ja schon seit vielen monaten sagen
diese aha regel die sollte von allen
menschen möglichst beibehalten werden
also die frage der grundsätzlichen des
grundsätzlichen nutzens von mir zielen
schutzmassnahmen gesprochen worden ich
finde im vergleich zu nahezu allen
anderen eingriffen oder maßnahmen die
wir ergreifen ist das zwar eine nervige
aber eine doch am ende auch handelbare
und für die allermeisten ja auch
mittlerweile irgendwie in den alltag
übergegangen und ich kann halt nur nur
immer wieder sagen und dafür werben dass
wir wirklich schritt für schritt gehen
und nicht und ich bezieht das nicht auf
ein einzelnes bundesland das ist mir
wichtig sondern eher auf die generelle
situation aber ich habe den eindruck
dass im moment wochenweise in einigen
ländern lockerungen gemacht werden und
ich wäre halt nur sehr dafür dass wenn
man eine lockerung schritt geht so war
es und ist es zwischen bund und ländern
vereinbart man erstmal zwei drei wochen
wartet welche folgen das für das
infektionsgeschehen hat und dann
möglicherweise den nächsten schritt geht
ich verstehe das alles bin auch
ungeduldig aber unsere ungeduld darf am
ende nicht zu übermut führen und das
heißt für mich eben am ende schritt für
schritt und zwar schritt für schritt
nicht jeden tag ein und jede woche ein
sondern so dass wir auch immer wieder
sehen können welche auswirkungen hat das
auf die infektionszahlen und mit blick
auf den einzelhandel geht's halt wenn
ich meine man muss es ja am ende
lebenspraktisch machen 33 kundinnen oder
kunden im schuhgeschäft im
bekleidungsgeschäft okay aber ich weiß
doch selbst wie es in manchem großen
elektronik geschäft ist am handy stand
wenn denn da keine begrenzung ist der
zahlen pro quadratmeter und auch
ansonsten keine masken und da ist
irgendein neues modell oder irgendwie
sonst was dann stehen da 30 leute in der
taube sollte es sind genau diese kleinen
situation die wir auch wieder haben
wollen die auch wiederkommen werden die
wir aber doch in der jetzigen phase noch
vermeiden können ohne dass es wirklich
eine belastung fürs leben ist im
einzelhandel jetzt eine zeitlang zu
öffnen ja aber dabei aufeinander
aufzupassen und das ist einfach meine
grundsätzliche bewertung
ansonsten liegt die verantwortung für
diese entscheidung und die zuständigkeit
der länder
dann die nächste frage frau wolff ja
vielen dank eine frage an herrn spahn am
zur situation in kinder- und
jugendpsychiatrie ich erkenntnis fans
über die belastungen möglicherweise vor
allem auch über klar in den kinder- und
jugendpsychiatrie plan stehen sie in
kontakt mit den sicher sich atrium gern
verwenden und kinder und jugendmediziner
also zuerst einmal mal ganz
grundsätzlich finde ich ist deswegen
ebenso wichtig wegen der zwei
verschiedene situation
belastungssituation und zum teil dann
auch psychotherapeutischen
notwendigkeiten die sich daraus ergeben
dass erstmal diese situation die wir
haben für viele belastend ist ist noch
keine behandlungsbedürftigkeit also dass
die zeit der einschränkung eine
belastende ist ist etwas mit dem wir
alle gemeinsam ja bestmöglich umgehen
müssen
man muss schauen wo entsteht daraus
etwas und das risiko ist natürlich da
für viele was gegebenenfalls auf den
behandlungsbedarf auslöst und ein
sechsjähriges kind hat jetzt ein
sechstel seines lebens mehr als ein
sechster seines lebens in der pandemie
gebracht verbracht manche sind
eingeschult worden und an die schule
noch gar nicht einmal von innen gesehen
das alles macht was und es macht glaube
ich sehr sicher uns ja offenkundig mit 6
oder 10 jährigen zwölfjährigen im
zweifel noch mehr als mit uns ist schon
macht in höherem alter
deswegen finde ich jetzt auch so wichtig
dass jetzt in dieser phase auch mit
blick auf impfungen auf im übrigen ja
auch nicht selten die stadtteile mit den
meisten kindern im übrigen irgendwie ist
da er geht mit blick auf info mit blick
auf kitas und schulen schutzkonzepte wir
incidence abhängig aber doch daneben
auch schnellstmöglich wieder so viel
normalität herstellen wie es geht das
wird der bezogen aus impfen auch ein
themen also ein nächster woche mit den
ländern was die situation die
behandlungssituation angeht gibt es ja
durchaus auch eine debatte zwischen den
verbänden und den fachleuten ob das der
begriff der trias wirklich ein
angemessener
ist an dieser stelle ich finde wir
sollten mit diesem begriff insgesamt in
unseren diskussionen etwas vorsichtiger
sein dass es wartezeiten gibt
das war schon ein problem vor dieser
pandemie das ist jetzt auch noch mal
verstärkt und deswegen tun wir alles um
entsprechende angebote zu unterstützen
sind auf allen ebenen im regelmäßigen
austausch aber gerade mit der situation
gesundheitlichen situation für kinder
und jugendliche möchte ich jetzt auch
noch mal sozusagen jenseits des
regulären austausches in mehreren
expertenrunden gespräche führen weil es
eine ist ja die situation psychisch aber
das andere ist was ist mit nicht
stattgefunden vorsorgeuntersuchungen was
ist mit nicht stattgefundenen impfung
was ist mit dem was jetzt im moment
wegen nicht normalem arzt und
medizinbetrieb auch jenseits der
pandemie nicht stattgefunden hat u1 u2
u6 all diese untersuchungen 646 weiß ich
der wwu untersuchung die wir haben
mehrere also für die für die jüngeren
haben vielfach so nicht stattgefunden
wir uns all diese themen möchte ich
gerne in mehreren runden auch mit den
entsprechenden verbänden noch einmal
erörtern nach lösungen auch da suchen
sein letztes weil ich diese woche auch
ein gespräch mit zum beispiel krisen
chat de hatte ich möchte auch dass wir
für so lernt aus dieser pandemie
angebote digitale angebote gerade wie
bei krisen chat de für unter 25-jährige
die tatsächlich auch einen unterschied
machen und von psychotherapeuten
psychologen jahr gemacht werden das
angebot das wird daraus auch lernen für
die zukunft auch stärker ergänzend
solche digitalen wege und angebote zu
haben
ergänzend das ist wichtig zu dem angebot
direkt in den praxen nachfrage dazu an
herrn bieler wenn über von von diesen
belastungen für kinder und jugendliche
die rede ist wieder dann noch mal
nachgefragt wie blicken sie dann darauf
aus den bereichen die einzelhandel
tourismus astronomie gelockert wird und
dann kitas und schulen noch nicht
flächendeckend und noch keine
flächendeckende rückkehr zum
präsenzunterricht gibt also sehen sie an
dass krebs angesichts der infektions
lage
die rückkehr der kinder in den schulen
ist ja eine vorgehensweise der einzelnen
länder die auch unterschiedlich
gehandhabt wird
ich möchte noch mal darauf hinweisen
dass die kinder ja auch durch die
infektion selber belastet sind also ich
möchte das nicht gegeneinander
ausspielen ich möchte noch mal
vielleicht ihnen ein paar zahlen sagen
warum der infektionsschutz auch bei
kindern eine rolle spielt es gibt drei
studien die ich erzählen möchte es gibt
eine italienische studie dass eine
geringe studie sind 120 also eine kleine
zahl 120 kinder durchschnittlich alter
elf jahre
hier sieht man dass nach 60 tagen und 42
prozent der kinder noch per sistieren
der symptome nach einer infektion haben
und es gibt eine andere studie aus
großbritannien da gibt es insgesamt eine
million teilnehmende da gibt es erste
schätzung zur prävalenz raten da sieht
man das bei kindern zwölf wochen bei
jungen erwachsenen 18 prozent das sind
junge erwachsene zwischen 25 34 jahren
und bei jugendlichen zwischen 12 und 60
jahren bei acht prozent und bei kindern
zwischen zwei und elf jahren bei 7,4
prozent immer noch symptome die mit
longo wie den eintrag zu bringen sind
genannt werden erschöpfung kopfschmerzen
husten myagi manche der kinder sind gar
nicht schulfähig dann gibt es eine große
nicht sagen nicht begutachtete britische
studie die basiert auf der nutzung von
apps da werden kinder systematisch
untersucht jugendliche zwischen fünf und
17 jahren
und die werden dann eingeteilt in zwei
gruppen die einen die negativ getestet
worden die anderen die positiv getestet
worden das sind 1700 kinder und
jugendliche je gruppe und da sieht man
dass 4,4 prozent der kinder und
jugendlichen noch die positiv getestet
waren nach mehr als 28 tagen noch
symptome haben die mit lankowitz in
zusammenhang gebracht werden können das
heißt also der infektionsschutz den
sollten wir auch weiter aufrechterhalten
aber man kann ja schule neben öffnen
auch mit hygiene konzert
das ist ja der entscheidende punkt und
ein aspekt auf den ich hinaus möchte
nochmals warum es auch so wichtig ist
dass man eben dann auch hoffentlich
zukünftig auch kinder bis 12 jahre
impfen kann ich habe ihn eben gesagt
dass eben auch diese kinder erkranken
können natürlich einen deutlich
geringeren prozent zahlen
aber wenn wir jetzt so gut impfen und
das ist ja wunderbar dann wird halt das
virus ja trotzdem nicht verschwinden und
dann können eben die kinder und die
jugendlichen kommen dann quasi mehr in
den fokus des virus darum ist es auch
wichtig dass man dort weiterhin
schutzmaßnahmen hält zu den vielleicht
könntest du den niedrigschwelligen
erfahrungen und angeboten weil zuerst ja
in einer kommune auftauchen bei kindern
und jugendlichen mache ich gerne also in
köln sind die schulen und die
kindergärten die infektions treiber
gewesen sondern da waren die zahlen
immer niedrig und wir haben aber auch
dadurch testung und durch sehr gezielt
kontakt nachverfolgung das immer
einigermaßen im griff behalten aber es
besteht natürlich immer die abwägung und
das erleben wir ja insbesondere als
träger der kindergärten öffnen wir die
kindergärten oder ob man wie sie nicht
und die notbetreuung und da komme ich
jetzt wieder zu den wohlhabenden
sozialräumen die notbetreuung wird da
häufiger in anspruch genommen da sind
mehr kinder sozusagen in den
einrichtungen als in den bevorzugten
stadtteilen und das kann man nur meines
erachtens auch durch die testung die wir
anbieten durch diese neue test der pcr
tests sind also wirklich aussagekräftig
im griff behalten
dann habe ich die nächste frage vom
kollegen gut andere pioneer an herrn
spahn eine frage zu den impfungen bei
dem über 12 jährigen ab wann und wo
sollen sie geimpft werden und wie gehen
sie damit um dass die stiko die impfung
in dieser altersgruppe wegen fehlender
daten nicht empfehlen will
also im zweifel weiß ja buchsteiner da
mehr als ich über die das was die stiko
tun wird das ist
ja noch gar nicht möglich diese
empfehlung der stiko weil die daten dazu
noch gar nicht da sind aber es gibt
diskussionen und diskussionen die aus
meiner sicht auch notwendig und richtig
ist
die verschiedene aspekte hat erstmal den
individuellen aspekt immer von nutzen
risiko einer impfung und der
individuellen entscheidung aber auch dem
was der professor wieder gerade gesagt
hat was wir an infektionsgeschehen sehen
und auch erwarten müssen umso mehr in
einer anderen altersgruppe geimpft sind
desto größer mag und kann das risiko in
einen anderen altersgruppen werden und
dem was wir auch an longo windtner
phänomenen sehen und deswegen ist mir
ein ist ganz ganz wichtig dass das eine
freiwillige informierte entscheidung ist
der eltern mit ihren kindern
beziehungsweise der jugendlichen und der
ärztin und ärzte
das wird ja die grundprämisse sein und
dann ist die empfehlung eine mögliche
empfehlung der ständigen impfkommission
dafür ein beitrag zur
entscheidungsfindung der auch wichtig
ist aber es ist tatsächlich ja eine
entscheidung der zu impfenden
beziehungsweise in jüngeren jahren ihre
eltern mit dem arzt der ärztin wir
jedenfalls werden im falle einer
zulassung die auch erst mal noch
erfolgen muss durch die europäische
arzneimittelbehörde mit den ländern und
den städten und landkreisen dieses
impfangebot geben und dann kann jeder
entscheiden ob er es annimmt dann habe
ich auf meiner liste frau bader als
nächste erspart ich hätte noch eine
frage zu der entscheidung gestern man
hat sich ja auch darauf geeinigt dass
quarantäne regelungen individuell nur
noch in ausnahmesituationen von den
ländern verhängt werden sollen dürfen
also wenn es virus mutationen gibt
beispielsweise wie zufrieden sind sie
mit dieser einigung von gestern auf eu
ebene
sie waren oft ich war gerade überlegt ob
sie die bundesländer main und ich
gestern eine sitzung verpasst hat naja
es ist am ende mit 27 mitgliedsstaaten
einer europäischen kommission mit einem
europäischen parlament nicht weniger
anspruchsvoll als in einer
ministerpräsidenten
ferenc tatsächlich zu einer einigung zu
kommen und zu einem kompromiss gerade
was quarantäne und reiseregelung angeht
haben wir als bundesrepublik deutschland
immer sehr dafür geworben dass es
möglichst einheitliche regeln in der eu
geben sollte gleichzeitig mussten und
müssen wir immer wieder aufs neue
feststellen dass die interessenlagen so
unterschiedlich sind dass das nicht
immer gelingt insofern werden wir auch
im lichte dieses kompromisses aber
weiterhin an unseren regelungen dort
auch festhalten
zufrieden mit richtig verstanden habe da
ist uns weiterhin möglich macht auch
unseren ansatz der vorsicht zu machen ja
aber wie gesagt die interessenlagen sind
halt sehr unterschiedlich weil es ja
schon zwischen den bundesländern so ist
und sind sie bei 27 mitgliedstaaten auch
für jemand wo der tourismus einen sehr
hohen anteil des bruttoinlandsproduktes
ausmacht macht mag die frage der
abwägung wie viel mobilität mache ich
wie möglich anders ausgehen als für
länder oder das bruttoinlandsprodukt
etwas weniger vom tourismus und von
externen tourismus abhängt der
kompromiss macht uns weiter ermöglicht
das zu tun was wir für richtig halten
und das ist okay wenn die geschafft vom
zdf hauptstadtstudio fragt an herrn
spahn ich würde gerne wissen ob der
spiegel -bericht richtig ist dass corona
genesene mit einer impfung die jrk keine
zweite bekommen müssen sich weiter
testen lassen müssen und wie sie hier
für gerechtigkeit zu sorgen wollen nein
es ist nicht richtig ist ein einfach ich
habe heute morgen selbst geschaut noch
einmal in die eigene verordnung was das
thema genesene geimpfte und getestete
angeht unterstehen sehr klar definiert
dass jemand als folge impft gilt wenn er
als genesener eine weitere impfung
erhalten hat und daher selbst ein
betroffener sozusagen bin nämlich
genesener und seit letzter woche
geimpfter habe ich jedenfalls immer mein
gelben
jetzt gerade nicht aber wenn ich damit
rechne ist zu brauchen
mein gelben impfausweis dabei und meinen
pcr test nach weißt du das ich gelesen
und impfung entsprechend nachweisen kann
es gibt mittlerweile viele impfpässe in
denen ausdrücklich vorne oder hinten je
nach druck auch die möglichkeit besteht
für den arzt eine durchgemachte
infektion nicht nur für bewohner oder
kur wird sondern auch für andere
erkrankungen und infektionen zu
bestätigen so dass das dann
gegebenenfalls auch in einem passt geld
was das thema ist dass ich finde ich
nicht dass alles richtig verstanden habe
ist das reisen
aber da gibt es tatsächlich auf der
ganzen welt noch keine einheitliche
regelung das ist ja der vorteil sind wir
wieder beim thema europäische union wenn
wir uns in der europäischen union hat
auf etwas einigen da schon mal für 27
staaten gilt hat das immer auch die
chance ein stück standard für die welt
zu setzen zumal die ja nicht weniger in
die eu einreisen wollen aus der ganzen
welt und deswegen bemühen wir uns sehr
in der eu wie auch am wochenende über
pfingsten jedes jahr über pfingsten ist
ja weltgesundheitsversammlung auch bei
der wm sehr darum dass da eine
einheitlichkeit ist in der frage
genesene einmal geimpft gelten
tatsächlich als vollständig geschützt
und geimpft aber für das innerdeutsche
jedenfalls ist das klar geregelt
denn die nächste frage stand des frau
spielern eine frage an frau katharina
binz ich sagen das ist eine art
verteilungskampf gibt oder streit dass
man jetzt sagen so darf ich jetzt eben
in bestimmten brennen und das war dafür
entwickelt später an anderer stelle dann
wollte ich die fragen wir uns ersparen
nochmal zu den therapieplätzen auch das
tatsächlich überlegen ob es gibt hier
therapieplätze aufzustocken weil es
nicht nur jugendliche haben
pardon verschieden und ich kann sie
gerne noch mal auf die listung auf
stützen aber das war ja ja alle anderen
kollegen warten aus der landes
also es gab schon am anfang diskussion
darüber ob es gerecht sei
in den wohlhabenden sozialräumen zu
impfen und damit auch eine priorisierung
aufzuheben das will ich nicht verhehlen
aber es ist uns gelungen gut zu
kommunizieren dass das wenn wir dort die
infektionszahlen unter bekommen dass das
der ganzen stadt hilft und ich habe auch
festgestellt dass die menschen diese
unterstützende hilfe wirklich als große
wertschätzung wahrgenommen haben und das
natürlich auch in ihren communitys
weiter tragen also denen ist endlich mal
was geschehen was sie viele jahre oder
jahrzehnte vermisst haben nämlich dass
sie mal bevorzugt behandelt worden zu
der frage der psychotherapeutischen
angebote in deutschland gibt es
tatsächlich eine auch notwendige
diskussion schon vor der pandemie wir
haben die zahl der psychotherapeuten
sitzt so muss jetzt technisch praktisch
zu machen
in den letzten jahren um einige tausend
deutschlandweit erhöht durch
verschiedene gesetzliche anpassungen und
entscheidungen der folge des gemeinsamen
bundesausschusses wir stellen aber
gleichzeitig auch fest dass in regionen
mit der höchsten in der größeren zahl
von psychotherapeuten pro einwohner
nicht per se die wartezeiten kürzer sind
was man ja vermuten würde dass da wo die
versorgungsdichte höher ist dann auch
weniger wartezeiten entstehen es scheint
teilweise eher das gegenteil der fall zu
sein war sehr deutlich macht dass es vor
allem darum eine steuerung geht weil
nicht selten diejenigen die am
dringendsten eine behandlung bräuchten
das ist anders als vielfach bei
somatischen erkrankungen am wenigsten
auch für sich selbst in der lage sind
diese behandlung
zu erreichen sich um sie zu kümmern auch
aktiv eben vor allem auch dann wenn das
angebot nicht niedrigschwellig und
einfach zu erreichen ist und deswegen
haben wir ja auch den gemeinsamen
bundesausschuss also kassen
krankenhäuser ärzteschaft beauftragt
patientenvertreter dabei und sie sind
gerade in den beim bas finale
behandlungen immer noch eine frage von
monaten aber in den abschließenden
beratungen dazu wie wird besser übrigens
von den niedrigschwelligen angeboten der
kommunen vor ort das fängt ja an oft
dann in der schuldnerberatung in der
suchtberatung in der jugendhilfe
beratungs und behandlungsbedarf zu
erkennen und zu vernetzen dann mit dem
psychotherapeutischen angeboten mit den
hausärztlichen strukturen diese
vernetzung die steuerung ist mindestens
so wichtig wie die zahl der sitze und da
besser zu werden haben wir bereits
gesetzlich angelegt es in der umsetzung
aber es ist eben wie uns diese pandemie
zeigt bei weitem noch nicht gut genug
die nächste vorher wüsste herr professor
dr sie haben gerade erzählt von den
gefahren für lankowitz bei kindern sie
eigentlich darauf internationale studien
berufen
der sprecher des bundesverbandes der
kinder- und jugendärzte dr maske sagt
sie müssen schon mit einer sehr großen
lupe suchen um fälle von longbow witt
bei kindern zu entdecken was haben sie
für konkrete zahlen aus deutschland für
erkenntnisse die ihre position
rechtfertigen und herr sparen sie haben
sich impfen lassen die stiko empfiehlt
aber für genesene wegen des impfens dass
sie sich nicht impfen lassen soll wie
passt das zusammen dann kehrt ja aus
kenntnisse aus deutschland gibt es dazu
kaum erkenntnisse reitschuster was wir
in deutschland haben ist ein register
der deutschen gesellschaft für
pädiatrische infektiologie ich glaube
dass besteht seit was 7 märz oder april
letzten jahres
und dort stand 16 fünfter sind 1522
kinder und jugendliche bis 19 jahre also
in deutschland jetzt konkret von
deutschland wurden aufgenommen stationär
aufgenommen das heißt also waren
krankenhaus pflichtig und von diesen
1522 sind 5
also das sind dann stand 16 53 74 kinder
mussten intensivmedizinisch behandelt
werden über longo fit wie sie sagen gibt
es noch keine hinreichenden
untersuchungen
es gibt die datenlage ist er definitiv
eingeschränkt es gibt kaum systematisch
erhobenen daten zu lamco wird aber die
universität zürich
die die erstellt einen sogenannten
living reviews das heißt diese daten
werden auch kommen aber das ist auch der
grund warum ich ihn im garten aus
anderen ländern genannt habe das heißt
wir wissen ja schon es gibt einen sinn
bei einzelnen fällen gibt es auch dieses
multi systemische entzündungs syndrom
und ist oder das pda tische multi
systemische entzündungs syndrom also
etwas was mir wichtig ist ist klar dass
eben auch kinder erkranken können in
einer deutlich geringeren häufigkeit als
das bei erwachsenen der falls also je
älter sozusagen desto größer ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass man schwer
erkrankt aber ich möchte eben zum einen
darauf hinweisen dass auch kinder schwer
erkranken können wenn ich jetzt so
richtig im kopf haben sind bislang in
deutschland etwa 20 kinder verstorben in
21 und ich möchte dabei immer wieder
wirklich was mir wirklich wichtig ist
auch hinzuweisen ist je mehr menschen
wie dann glücklicherweise und zurecht
und wichtiger weise impfen
und je mehr kommt eben eine
infektionsdruck auf immer jüngere das
heißt also dann wird auch die zahl die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass ich dann jüngere
infizieren wird daneben auch größer und
ich finde wir dürfen eben wir müssen
eben versuchen alle altersklassen egal
welches alter egal welcher ethnie sonst
was wir müssen alle menschen in unserem
land so gut wie möglich vor dieser
infektion schützen ja und da gibt es im
maßnahmen die wir die war einfach im
kopf haben sollten um das zu verhindern
also das internet hilft der ein schuss
der empfehlung der stiko personen die
eine pcr gesicherte saß co2 infektion
durchgemacht haben sollten in der regel
sechs monate nach genesung eine kurve 19
impfstoffdosis erhalten das ist die
empfehlung der ständigen impfkommission
und der bin ich gefolgt
das kann man ja leicht nachprüfen aber
im übrigen macht sinn auch gerade in
dieser phase der pandemie dass alle sich
um einen vollständigen impfschutz
bemühen
also ich finde es wichtig dass genesene
insbesondere auch mit fall wegfall der
priorisierung den vollständigen
impfschutz und im mobilitäts schutz
damit erreichen und kann sie nur bitten
mit mir gemeinsam in allen medien wo sie
können für zinsen zu werben auch in dem
fall die nächste frage ja dass er wieder
wie schätzen sie die ausbreitung der
englischen variante in europa in
deutschland rein und ersparen
sie haben gerade vor sich hat den
öffnungen schritten gemahnt konkret
gehen ihnen die öffnung schritte derzeit
zu schnell
ja also zunächst einmal gibt es eben
immer wieder neue varianten
darauf haben wir länger hingewiesen und
es ist wichtig dass wir das im auge
behalten und diese varianten bedeuten ja
zum einen dass das erbgut des virus sich
ändert und das ist eben oft auch damit
einhergehend dass sich die biologischen
eigenschaften von diesen viren ändern
und was die zwei biologischen
eigenschaften die uns interessieren sind
zum einen die übertragbarkeit also sind
sie besser übertragbar sie erinnern sich
an b 11 7 das ist der grund für die
dritte welle gewesen dass diese variante
deutlich höhere übertragbarkeit hatte
als die vorherigen und das zweite was
uns interessiert ist eben dieser aspekt
ob der impfschutz noch voll trägt und
bei base dass die die variante die sie
ansprechen heißt der b 16 17
diese variante da ist der kenntnisstand
noch lückenhaft was wir wissen ist dass
diese variante sich massivst und
wirklich dramatisch in indien
ausgebreitet hat wir wissen aber
momentan noch nicht ob das daran liegt
dass diese variante wegen höhere
übertragbarkeit es gibt vermutungen
erste daten dazu
wir sind dazu auch kontinuierlichen
austausch mit unseren nachbarländern
insbesondere im vereinigten königreich
dort gibt es ja
mehrere viele fälle sind bislang etwas
über 200 glaube ich hab's nicht genau im
kopf und dort beobachten die kollegen
das sehr genau da gibt es die vermutung
dass sie deutlich höhere tanz
übertragbarkeit hat aber das ist noch
nicht wirklich evident die denken dass
wir das in den nächsten ein zwei wochen
aber fest suchen können das sagen mir
die kollegen aus dem vor einigen
königreich das heißt das müssen wir
beachten wir haben wir deshalb auch für
bestimmte varianten haben die übrigens
letzte woche auch zu einer berlin oft
konzern gemacht diese variante also die
ist halt nicht unter beobachtung
sie ist eine die uns schon sorgen macht
darum haben wir ja auch bestimmte
quarantänemaßnahmen zu hoch gefahren
damit menschen die damit infiziert
werden noch stringenter behandelt werden
der zweite aspekt ist ja dieses immun
ist
und da gibt es auch nur sehr limitierte
studien aber die studien die wir bisher
haben die sagen das ist wahrscheinlich
eine geringere der impfschutz wird
geringer sein aber in einem
überschaubaren maß es gibt bei dieser
variante insbesondere drei aminosäure
austauschen das ist diese 484 die haben
sie schon oft gehört das ist dann diese
452 und 681 das sind alles varianten die
etwas mit der interaktion mit dem
immunsystem zu tun haben also wir gehen
da von außen leicht reduzierter im
schutz und wie gesagt das ist der grund
warum wir schnell impfen müssen um
insgesamt die zahlen so schnell wie
möglich runter zu kriegen das ziel von
uns allen muss sein incidents
runterzubringen dann spielen alle diese
varianten können wir können alles
leichter manager wenn wir die niedrige
intelligenz haben das leben wird für uns
alle besser wir haben weniger kranke wir
können ausbrüche schneller erkennen ein
denn als ziel muss sein die inzidenz
unterzubringen
das ist das entscheidende dafür sollten
wir alles tun eigentlich kurz ergänzen
darf zum vereinigten königreich weil uns
das besorgt und weil wir vermeiden
wollen dass diese variante in
deutschland sich zu stark verbreitet
oder überhaupt verbreitet werden wir
gerade auch das vereinigte königreich
als reise ort rückreise orts oder
einreise ort noch mal neu innerhalb der
bundesregierung im laufe des tages was
die frage angeht
öffnung schritte na ich kann da immer
nur sie zu einer einfachen grundregeln
faustformel zurückkommen er hat alles
unter 100 alles was draußen ist ist
erstmal etwas was ich jedenfalls
richtiger findet zuerst zu öffnen
alles was test gestützt ist und sehr
stark test gestützt ist und bleibt auch
mit den test angeboten die wir haben und
andersrum alles was drin ist vor allem
bei längerem aufenthalt drin und auch
noch ohne maske empfehle ich halt sehr
dass im zweifel noch ein paar wochen
abzuwarten bis die instanzen niedriger
sind ich meine wir können auch jetzt
wirklich schritte gemeinsam gehen auch
lang erhoffte und erwartete und ersehnte
schritte der biergarten um den mann als
synonym zu nehmen für die
außengastronomie im einzelhandel
zusätzlich wieder zu öffnen aldi und das
waren ja viele bereiche die jetzt nicht
haben geöffnet sein können über viele
viele monate in den schulen mit
entsprechendem schutz konzepten mit
maske mit test dann entsprechend zu
öffnen
aber um das abzusichern werde ich
jedenfalls sehr dafür und so ist es
eigentlich auch vereinbart instituts
abhängig
das was drinnen ist und was einen
längeren aufenthalt drinnen miteinander
im zweifel noch sprechend beim essen
bedeutet möglichst spät erst zu öffnen
weil umso niedriger wir die incidents
jetzt noch kriegen bis zum sommer desto
besser kann dieser sommer werden wir
sind auf einem guten weg meine werte vor
vier wochen wäre bei einführung der
bundesliga heute schon eine situation
haben wo deutlich unter 100 landkreise
und städte überhaupt noch betroffen sind
weil sie über 100 liegen und das jetzt
sozusagen zu kombinieren öffnung
schritte die auch wichtig sind gemeinsam
für uns auch zu sehen dass wir das
erreicht haben ohne zu schnell zu
schreiten
weil wir dann irgendwann sonst
zurückschreiben müssten das wollen wir
vermeiden
darum geht's noch genau eine
viertelstunde ich habe immer noch 8
rückmeldung vielleicht schaffen wir das
ja die nächste hatte kreuz weg ersparen
sie haben selbst gesagt vor vier wochen
hätte niemand gedacht dass in grenzen so
schnell runter gehen nicht würde oder
kaum jemand ich würde noch mal
interessieren um auch die das
zurückführen und auch am bieler weil es
ist ja nicht nur das sind wir jetzt
einen schnellen rückgang hat man
zunächst 20 prozent pro woche der hat
sich jetzt noch mal beschleunigt auf 30%
pro woche pro jahr geschafft worden ist
und eher gelockert würde mich mal
interessieren was ihre erklärung dafür
ist dass wirklich nur an impfen oder
kommt dass er nochmal beschleunigt
das ist ohne zweifel eine kombination
aus mehreren faktoren ist halt was zu
tun das haben wir jetzt mehrfach gesehen
und ja nicht nur in deutschland über die
letzten monate damit dass viele
bürgerinnen und bürger angesichts einer
auch wieder sich verschärfenden
situation auf den intensivstationen die
diskussionen die es gibt
miteinander zur jeweiligen lage auch vor
ort und in deutschland und in europa
durchaus auch diese situationen zu sehen
in indien was dieses virus anrichten
kann immer laufen lässt bei vielen schon
zur verhaltensänderung führt dazu kommt
das ist sozusagen die individuelle
entscheidung von bürgerinnen und bürgern
dazu kommt entschlossene staatliches
handeln dass wir sie wissen ich mir
schon im zweifel vor ostern gewünscht
hätte das aber dann wir ja gemeinsam
noch erreicht haben
das einen entsprechenden unterschied
macht das impfen wir uns noch mal sagen
weil ich das beeindruckend finde ostern
12 erst geimpft pfingsten sieben wochen
40 prozent erst geimpft zeigt ja wie
viel mehr wie auch durch das impfen
haben schon ein unterschied machen
können und dann ohne zweifel ja auch die
situation das ist einfach wieder schöner
und angenehmer ist draussen zu sein und
draußen das also sind einfach ganz
vielen faktoren und facetten die
zusammenspielen die diesen
entscheidenden unterschied machen und so
ist dass er mit exponentiellen wachstum
in beide richtungen was exponentiell
wächst wenn der wert 0 6 oder 07 ist
also wir haben jetzt schon sechs noch
was gehabt das hat immer schon ziemlich
lange nicht mehr
was wenn 11 und 12 nicht nur der
unterschied der kleine unterschied ist
den es sich anfühlt sondern eben ein
deutlicher in der dynamik so ist das bei
0 9 oder 07 er wert eben auch und so
dass entsprechend exponentiell jetzt
auch runter wenn wir uns das erhalten
und das ist auch beim thema vorher
öffnen ja bin ich ja auch dafür an den
richtigen stellen aber eben an den
richtigen stellen ich kann das
eigentlich nicht ergänzen das ist genau
die erklärung es gibt auch immer mehr
systematischen untersuchungen die das
eben zeigen dass es diese vielzahl der
maßnahmen ist und das ist auch wichtig
wir sprechen da oft ich habe mich oft
das wort werkzeugkasten benutzt aber
meine leute sagen ich sollte lieber
sagen multi komponenten werden nicht
aber der entscheidende punkt ist
wirklich dass eben diese vielzahl die
die maßnahmen zusammen so eine hohe
wirkung haben das ist mir auch so
wichtig dass wir das auch nicht
gedanklich immer wieder das eine gegen
das andere ausspielen wenn wir dann
alles schwächen ja also ich sehe es auch
als einen faktor der dessen verschiedene
faktoren die zusammenspielen
aber das heißt im umkehrschluss wenn wir
dann eben einen dieser faktoren dann
auch nachlassen dann ist eben die chance
auch wieder da das virus eben wieder
statt und darum appellieren wir so
intensiv daran dass man schrittweise
öffnet und diese grundregeln einfach
behält ich sehe auch gerade das masken
tragen als einen sehr geringen
eingriffen in die innersten das
freiheitliche leben von uns einzeln die
nächste frage von frau breu
gesundheitspolitischer
informationsdienst ersparen setzen sie
sich dafür ein dass die
freiheitsbestrebungen für alle also
geimpfte genesener und umgehend der
entfallen wenn ein staatsbürgerinnen ein
impf angebot unterbreitet wurde
also grundsätzlich ist das der zeitpunkt
an dem wir auch schon jede will ich
jetzt noch nicht abschließend sagen aber
doch wir die allermeisten
einschränkung aus meiner sicht
tatsächlich auch aufgeben könnten vor
allem diejenigen die auch dem
gegenseitigen schutz denen ich finde wer
das angebot bekommt sich zu schützen
durchimpfung der kann dann sozusagen
nicht erwarten dass alle anderen
beständig auf ihn oder sie aufpassen
worauf wir aber alle gemeinsam aufpassen
sollten sind auf diejenigen die sich
nicht impfen lassen können etwa weil sie
noch in entsprechendem alter sind oder
weil sie bestimmte vorerkrankungen
vielleicht haben die das nicht angezeigt
sein lassen und deswegen hängt das eben
auch ein stück weit davon ab welche
impfquote wir erreichen wir sehen jetzt
gerade einige länder wo schon bei 50
plus das deutlich erlahmt das mit dem
sich impfen lassen
eine solche situation trotz impfangebot
an alle wäre jetzt eine die noch nicht
unproblematisch wäre auch nicht für die
frage was das für die überlastung des
gesundheitswesens bedeuten kann wenn
sich viele millionen gleichzeitig
infizieren
insofern würde ich das ergänzen wollen
in der fragestellung wenn alle ein
angebot bekommen haben und jedenfalls
hinreichend viele ist auch angenommen
haben aber auf den letzten wären wir
sicherlich nicht warten können und ich
müssen und sollten wir auch nicht aus
fairnessgründen wenn denn dann
tatsächlich alle kunden die nächste
frage von herrn jung
ich wurde damals in niedersachsen kommen
und dem ende der masken pflichtet halten
sie auch dabei offenbar beide für eine
ziemlich dumme idee wieder können sie
nochmal erzählen erklären wie gefährlich
diese lockerung ist dass ich einmal nach
oben sind nicht mal 15 prozent geimpft
in israel wo fast alle geimpft sind und
eine inzidenz von zwei herrscht gibt es
auch noch eine maske pflicht wie kann
das sein wie gefährlich ist das ein frau
rega niedersachsen regierung begründet
das ja mit den forderungen der
einzelhandels lobby die druck macht und
behauptet das ist alles kein treiber
desinfektions geschehens warum fragen
sie eigentlich nicht der lobby weg wie
warum
können sie sich da wehren gegen wenn sie
mich so direkt fragen vermutlich dass
ich den druck leichter aushalten weil
ich nicht so sehr davon abhängig bin
wissen sie als oberbürgermeisterin ist
es ja auch wirklich eine verpflichtung
und das hat man ja geschworen ja dass
man alles tut um schaden von der stadt
abzuwenden und das ist dann weniger von
politischen entscheidungen bestimmt als
von maßnahmen der gefahrenabwehr das
habe ich eben gesagt und so betrachte
ich auch mein handeln ich über gefahren
habe wer aus und das macht der gesamte
krisenstab also das kann ich also die
frage wie gefährlich das nicht mehr
tragen von masken das kann ich nicht
quantifizieren aber es gibt verschiedene
untersuchungen die sagen dass es einige
prozent sind je nachdem es hängt immer
davon ab kommen wir gerade besprochen
welche anderen maßen abend noch
durchgeführt werden oder nicht
durchgeführt werden ist es ganz klar
dass es eher wenn man das in die
gesamtrechnung einzige sind mehrere
prozent je nach dem können es mehr als
10 15 prozent der gesamtwirkung sein je
nachdem welche studien man sich anschaut
dass beruht auf modellierungen das
beruht auf beobachtungen studien als es
keine so ganz harte evidenz aber masken
nummer in abhängigkeit des umfeldes
haben die eine große können ihnen große
wirkung haben dann die nächste frage
frau kollegen ganz hinten her
angelika slavik von der süddeutschen
zeitung bin ich ich hätte noch eine
frage zum thema urlaubsreisen und zwar
konkret die situation von eltern von
ungeimpften kindern worauf sollen die
sich dann einstellen also sollten wir
damit rechnen dass das funktioniert
sommerurlaub oder gibt es daher darum
nicht weiter zu reisen als bis zur
ostsee also zuerst einmal ich verstehe
total das bedürfnis auch noch diesen
monaten auch diesen dunklen monaten des
winters aber auch diesen harten monaten
nach urlaub und urlaubsplanung und
gleichzeitig ist jetzt in der frage in
einer pandemie die eine per definitionem
weltweite ist und einer die eben auch
mit mobilität zu tun hat auf der welt
kann ich halt nur dafür werben jetzt
jedenfalls mal in den nächsten wochen
und monaten bei der urlaubsplanung wir
reden jetzt hier nicht über zwingend
notwendige reisen über sehr wünschbare
reisen über nachvollziehbare wünsche
aber nicht zwingend notwendige
tatsächlich erst mal die region in den
blick zu nehmen die ein sehr niedriges
infektionsgeschehen haben dann stellt
sich die frage von games und getestet
auch nicht so also vor allem bei der
frage von quarantäne da nicht bei
flugverkehr nach deutschland aus dem
ausland muss jeder getestet werden jeder
egal aus welchem gebiet er zurück kommt
aus kämpft oder gelesen
die quarantäne frage ist abhängig von
der einstufung des gebiets aus dem man
zurückkehrt und die frage risikogebiet
haben wir jetzt ja noch mal erleichtert
dass man durch aktives vorzeigen eines
negativ testes nach einreise
die quarantäne deutlich abkürzen kann
gleichzeitig sind wir bei residenz und
virusvarianten gebieten aus guten grund
sehr streng
deswegen kenne ich halt nur empfehlen
reiseplanung so zu machen dass sie vor
allem regionen geht die erwartbar eine
niedrige dirigent sie denn zu 100
prozent sicherheit gibt einem aber
tatsächlich ja keiner worauf ja auch
viele reiseveranstalter mittlerweile
reagiert haben mit der möglichkeit
kurzfristig auch stornieren oder
umbuchen zu können und der grundsatz
dass man also ich mache urlaub in
deutschland
als einmal mehr frauen neue hd fragt
wahrscheinlich am besten an professor
wieder warum wurde die angestrebte
herdenimmunität er ist von 60 auf 70 und
jetzt auf 80 prozent hochgesetzt
die wurde nicht hoch gesetzt die frage
sie vorlesen dass das hängt damit
zusammen mit der übertragbarkeit also
dem dem rwe zum berühmten erwehrt der
wert der die jetzige dominieren das sind
ja immer noch über 90 prozent aller
viren in unserem land sind diese virus
linie b 11 7 und der wert dieser virus
variante ist höher das heißt sie kann
mehr übertragen das heißt also ein
infizierter infiziert mehr anderem
dadurch ergibt sich einfach dass man
insgesamt mehr menschen impfen muss und
je nachdem wie hoch der wert ist ändert
sich der anteil der menschen geimpft
werden müssen und das ganze geschehen
einzudämmen wir mal ein virus das hat
ein wahnsinnig holen wer erwartet dass
das ist das masernvirus der liegt bei 16
oder 18 also deutlich höheren noch und
das ist der grund warum wir da eben dann
auch eine impfrate von mehr als wenn ich
das richtig im kopf ab 75 79 95 97
prozent haben ist es hängt also von der
biologischen eigenschaften des erregers
ab und dieser und erreger verändern sich
und natürlich wenn wir jetzt 100.000
millionen menschen infiziert haben bei
jedem sprung eines virus zu einem
anderen infizierten besteht die chance
dass es sich verändert das erbgut
verändert wird und das ist einer der
gründe warum war eben noch mal die
inzidenz runterbringen müssen damit auch
weniger würde gibt und sich das virus
weniger schnell verändert also das ist
ein airbag im moment so ist und ich gehe
mal davon aus dass er so bleibt patrick
hollstein von apotheker talker fragt wie
soll der genesene nach west
funktionieren wer sind die aufgabe
übernehmen die ärzte haben vorbehalte
bezüglich verlässlicher methodik mit die
methodik für den genesenen nachweis ist
jedenfalls was die rechtslage angeht und
die verordnung angeht eindeutig
definiert das ist nämlich ein pcr test
am ende
also positiv 28 tage her ist und dann
maximal sechs monate dann müsste die
impfung erfolgen die dann ja
logischerweise auch sinn macht dann habe
ich noch zwei fragen vielleicht schaffen
wir das noch ein freispiel kammern und
dann habe ich alle abgearbeitet
er regte an noch mal zwischenebene sie
hatten ja letzte woche gefordert bei der
bestellung von künftigen impfstoff
diesem portfolio also zu wählen also
nicht nur auf einen hersteller wie
biontech zu setzen
jetzt gab's gestern die beratung was es
da rausgekommen haben sie sich mit ihrer
empfehlung ihrer forderung durchsetzen
können wird die eu-kommission bei
mehreren herstellern bestellen
jedenfalls hatte es gestern bei der
runde der mitgliedstaaten und das haben
sich auch nahezu alle zu wort gemeldet
eine sehr sehr breite eine sehr sehr
große mehrheitliche unterstützung für
unseren vorschlag gegeben
ein portfolio ansatz zu wählen wenn denn
auch den 2+2 ansatz was meinen wir damit
mindestens 2 mrd logan im portfolio zu
haben und mindestens zwei weitere
technologien also entweder protein
vektorbasierte tod im stoff das muss man
dann schauen in den verhandlungen und
den angeboten aber tatsächlich eben auf
mehr also so wichtig der vertrag mit
bayern tech fasern die 1,8 milliarden
dosen für 20 22 und 23 sind und wir
haben auch sehr unterstützt zügig zu
diesem vertrag zu kommen mit ja auch den
ausgestaltung die da nun mit den letzten
löchern drin sind also wichtig dieser
vertrag ist so wichtig finde ich es
tatsächlich so wie schon im letzten jahr
nicht nur auf dieses eine pferd zu
setzen und da gab es eine sehr sehr
breite unterstützung von nahezu allen
wortmeldungen von kolleginnen kollegen
aus den mitgliedsstaaten und ich habe
die kommission so verstanden dass das
auch unser gemeinsames ansehnlich und
frisch schlägt man mit der letzten tage
ich habe mal eine frage zur bh nächste
woche in der krone woche ist die
weltgesundheitsversammlung mister sparen
beurteilen sie die arbeit der wehr
was glauben sie welche reformen dringend
notwendig die
weltgesundheitsorganisation und die
frage wo übrigens ja auch herr professor
wieder für uns federführenden einer der
reformen arbeitsgruppen oder panels zur
nationalen international health
recreation also internationalen
gesundheits regulierung internationalen
gesundheits gesetzgebung mit dabei ist
beschäftigt sich sehr intensiv in
verschiedensten arbeitsgruppen und
panels seit monaten mit reformen fragen
und das wird jetzt eine erste
bestandsaufnahme geben bei der
weltgesundheitsversammlung wir haben da
zwei drei dinge und kurz die uns sehr
sehr wichtig sind das erste was wir sehr
wichtig finden ist ein commitment aller
mitgliedstaaten die vero auch
auszustatten so dass sie ihre aufgaben
erfüllen kann es ist kein guter
dauerzustand wenn private geldgeber
einen größeren anteil vielfach haben in
vielen in vielerlei hinsicht als die
staatlichen und eine organisation wie
die weltgesundheitsorganisation kann nur
so gut sein wie die mitgliedstaaten sie
sein lassen
dafür braucht es finanzielle ressourcen
dafür braucht es dann aber auch
kooperation eine
weltgesundheitsorganisation kann etwa im
falle eines ausbruchs sei es ebola im
kongo oder das co2 in china oder was
auch immer in deutschland oder kanada
nur so gut sein wie der mitgliedstaat
dann auch in kooperation informationen
gibt informationen möglich macht
kooperation möglich macht also diese
erste frage das selbstverständnis
miteinander zu haben dass man die
veronique mit aufgaben überfrachten kann
wenn man sie nicht gleichzeitig oder
betrachten kann so sonst ist sie
überfrachte wenn man nicht gleichzeitig
hier die notwendigen ressourcen und
möglichkeiten dafür gibt es zweite ist
eine höhere verbindlichkeit von
internationalen gesundheitsvorschriften
jetzt habe ich den richtigen begriff von
wir haben übrigens ein deutsches gesetz
seit das habe ich selber damals noch als
berichterstatter begleitet im bundestag
78 jahren zur umsetzung internationaler
gesundheitsvorschriften die wahrheit ist
er steht drin dass bestimmte flughäfen
und seehäfen in deutschland bestimmte
dinge vorhalten müssen zum beispiel da
stehen bestimmte meldepflichten und
vorgehensweisen drin die wahrheit ist
diese pandemie hat uns gezeigt dass wir
da nicht gut genug sind und deswegen
haben wir im pakt für den led für den
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst
ausdrücklich zum beispiel
investitionsmittel für die
internationalen flug- und seehäfen in
deutschland um dort auch baulich und von
den ressourcen her vorkehrungen zu
treffen für pandemie situation die sind
nämlich hat mir selbst ein zwei
angeschaut noch nicht so baulich auch an
einem fotografen in frankfurt bei aller
sonstigen infrastruktur aber auch bei
allen anderen flughäfen internationalen
ich will man sich dass sich das wünschen
würde und das dritte sind strukturelle
fragen ohne jetzt zu sehr in die details
zu gehen aber grundsätzlich die frage
wie ist die weltgesundheitsorganisation
so organisiert dass politische fragen
und fachliche fragen zwar natürlich
immer miteinander verwoben sind das ist
ja unser gemeinsamer alltag aber am ende
nicht die politischen fragen etwa in
einer ausbruch situation die fachlichen
einschätzung überwiegen also die trennt
man so die entscheidungswege und auch
organisationsform auch für die merchants
unit dass da nicht die politik immer
mehr bestimmt als das was fachlich
notwendig wäre sie nur drei wichtige
punkte wo wir uns sehr sehr stark
engagieren wo wir auch mit frankreich
zusammen
vorschläge gemacht haben für
entsprechende reformen die dann ja zu
einer gemeinsamen eu position geführt
haben wo wir weiterhin auch noch partner
in der welt suchen mit uns dieser
reformansätze zu betreiben dass die usa
nun mehr dabei sind und bleiben ist
dabei sehr ermutigend dann sind wir am
ende ich bedanke mich ganz herzlich für
das kommt für die geduld von professor
viele minister sparen und ich schliesse
die pressekonferenz